>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WHAT A WEEK AND IT’S ONLY
THURSDAY.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN ONLY ONE
STORY IN WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TALK NOT JUST THIS
WEEK BUT OVER THE LAST MONTH
ABOUT VIOLENT EXTREMISM AND THE
PEOPLE WHO EMBRACE IT.
THE DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
THOSE VIOLENT ARE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS WE ARE TOLD.
THEY MUST BE PUT DOWN BY FORCE.
THE WAR ON TERROR HAS MOVED
STATEWIDE EXTREMISTS HAVE
BREACHED OUR WALLS THEY ARE
INSIDE OUR COUNTRY AND IN
RESPONSE WE MUST HUNT THEM DOWN.
DOING IT IS EXISTENTIAL.
OUR COUNTRY DEPEND ON IT.
OUR LIVES DEPEND ON IT.
WE ARE HEARING THOSE WORDS
NONSTOP ON CABLE NEWS.
NOT JUST ON CABLE NEWS.
WE ARE HEARING THE VERY SAME
THING FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS
INCLUDING SOME REPUBLICAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
WE ARE HEARING IT FROM THE
LEADERS OF FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
WE ARE HEARING IT FROM THE
PENTAGON.
JUST THIS WEEK THE NEW SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE ORDERED THE ENTIRE
U.S. MILITARY TO, QUOTE, STAND
DOWN WHILE INVESTIGATORS CLEANSE
THE RANKS OF POLITICAL
EXTREMISTS.
AND OF COURSE WE ARE HEARING IT
FROM THE BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENT
FROM WALL STREET FROM THE TECH
MONOPOLIES FROM THE MASSIVE
MULTINATIONAL CORPORATIONS THAT
INCREASINGLY CONTROL THE
CONTOURS OF AMERICAN LIFE.
ALL OF THEM ARE NOW ON THE HUNT
FOR POLITICAL EXTREMISTS.
AND AT ONE LEVEL THAT DOES NOT
SOUND BAD.
BECAUSE NO SANE PERSON IS FOR
POLITICAL EXTREMISM, ESPECIALLY
VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
WE ARE AGAINST IT.
WE’RE FOR MODERATION.
WE ARE FOR INCREMENTAL CHANGE.
WE ARE FOR THE CONSENT OF THE
GOVERNED.
WE SAID THAT EVERY DAY FOR FOUR
YEARS AND WE MEANT IT.
WE DON’T LIKE EXTREMISTS EITHER.
WE ATTACK THEM REGULARLY.
BUT IT’S NOT ENOUGH TO BE
AGAINST SOMETHING.
YOU HAVE TO BE MORE PRECISE THAN
THAT WHAT IS IT THAT YOU ARE
AGAINST?
IN ORDER TO ROOT OUT A PROBLEM
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT IT IS.
YOU NEED A SENSE OF WHAT YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR.
YOU NEED A CLEAR SIGHT PICTURE.
YOU HAVE TO DEFINE THE TERMS.
AND HERE’S THE REMARKABLE THING
ABOUT THIS PUBLIC CONVERSATION
WE’RE HAVING.
NO ONE IS DOING THAT.
HAVE YOU NOTICED?
NONE OF THESE NEWLY ENERGIZED
AND HIGHLY EMPOWERED EXTREMIST
HUNTERS HAVE TOLD US EXACTLY
WHAT AN EXTREMIST IS.
SO WE ARE LEFT TO GUESS.
WE ARE LEFT TO LOOK AROUND
NERVOUSLY TO SEE IF WE CAN SPOT
ONE.
HOPING AGAINST HOPE THE WHOLE
TIME THEY ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
US, ARE THEY?
AND IF THEY ARE, WHAT EXACTLY
ARE THEY DOING?
HOW ARE THEY HUNTING THESE
EXTREMISTS THEY KEEP TELLING US
ABOUT BUT WILL NOT DESCRIBE?
WE NOW KNOW PART OF THE AN TO
THAT QUESTION.
THIS SHOW HAS OBTAINED
EXCLUSIVELY EVIDENCE THAT BANK
OF AMERICA, THE SECOND LARGEST
BANK IN THE COUNTRY WITH MORE
THAN 60 MILLION CUSTOMERS IS
ACTIVELY BUT SECRETLY ENGAGED IN
THE HUNT FOR EXTREMISTS IN
COOPERATION WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
BANK OF AMERICA IS, WITHOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OR THE CONSENT OF ITS
CUSTOMERS SHARING PRIVATE
INFORMATION WITH FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
BANK OF AMERICA EFFECTIVELY IS
ACTING AS AN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY.
BUT THEY ARE NOT TELLING YOU
ABOUT IT.
IN THE DAYS AFTER THE
JANUARY 6TH RIOT AT THE CAPITOL,
BANK OF AMERICA WENT THROUGH IT
OWN CUSTOMERS’ FINANCIAL AND
TRANSACTION RECORDS, A LOT OF
THEM.
NOW, THESE WERE THE PRIVATE
RECORDS OF AMERICANS WHO HAD
COMMITTED NO CRIME.
PEOPLE WHO AS FAR AS WE KNOW HAD
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6TH.
BUT AT THE REQUEST OF FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS, BANK OF AMERICA
SEARCHED ITS DATABASES LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE WHO FIT A SPECIFIC
PROFILE.
HERE’S WHAT THAT PROFILE WAS AND
WE ARE QUOTING:  CUSTOMERS
CONFIRMED AS TRANSACTING EITHER
THROUGH BANK ACCOUNT DEBIT CARD
OR CREDIT CARD PURCHASES IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. BETWEEN JANUARY
NUMBER TWO, PURCHASES MADE FOR
HOTELS, AIR B AND B, RSVPs IN
WASHINGTON, VIRGINIA, OR
MARYLAND AFTER JANUARY 6TH.
NUMBER THREE, ANY PURCHASE OF
WEAPONS OR AT A WEAPONS-RELATED
MERCHANT BETWEEN JANUARY 7TH AND
THEIR UPCOMING SUSPECTED STAY IN
THE D.C. AREA AROUND
INAUGURATION DAY.
AND, 4, AIRLINE RELATED
PURCHASES SINCE JANUARY 6TH.
END QUOTE.
SO WHAT TOO YOU NOTICE ABOUT
THAT PROFILE?
WELL, THE FIRST THING YOU NOTICE
IS THAT IT IS REMARKABLY BROAD.
ANY PURCHASES OF ANYTHING IN THE
CITY OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
ANY OVERNIGHT STAY ANYWHERE IN
THE THREE STATE AREA.
THAT’S SPANS HUNDREDS OF MILES.
ANY PURCHASE, NOT SIMPLY OF
LEGAL FIREARMS BUT, INSTEAD
ANYTHING BOUGHT FROM A, QUOTE,
WEAPONS RELATED MERCHANT,
T-SHIRT INCLUDED.
AND THEN ANY AIRLINE RELATED
PURCHASES.
NOT JUST FLIGHTS TO WASHINGTON,
FLIGHTS TO ANYWHERE, TO OMAHA,
TO THAILAND.
THAT IS A VERY, VERY WIDE NET.
AND ABSURDEDLY WIDE NET.
BANK OF AMERICA IDENTIFIED A
TOTAL OF 211 CUSTOMERS WHO MET
THESE, QUOTE, THRESHOLDS OF
INTEREST.
AND IT WAS AT THAT POINT THE
SHOW HAS LEARNED BANK OF AMERICA
TURNED OVER THE RESULTS OF ITS
INTERNAL SCAN TO FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
APPARENTLY WITHOUT NOTIFYING THE
CUSTOMERS WHO WERE BEING SPIED
UPON.
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS THEN
INTERVIEWED AT LEAST ONE OF
THESE UNEXPECTING PEOPLE.
AND THAT PERSON, WE LEARNED,
HADN’T DONE ANYTHING WRONG AND
IN THE END WAS CLEARED.
IMAGINE IF YOU WERE THAT PERSON?
THE FBI HAULS YOU IN FOR
QUESTIONING IN A TERROR
INVESTIGATION.
NOT BECAUSE YOU HAVE DONE
ANYTHING SUSPICIOUS.
YOU HAVEN’T.
YOU BOUGHT PLANE TICKETS AND
VISITED YOUR COUNTRY’S CAPITOL.
YOU THOUGHT YOU COULD DO THAT.
YOU THOUGHT IT WAS YOUR COUNTRY.
NOW THEY ARE SWEATING YOU
BECAUSE YOUR BANK, WHICH YOU
TRUST WITH YOUR MOST PRIVATE
INFORMATION, INFORMATION OF
EVERYTHING YOU BUY HAS RATTED
YOU OUT TO THE FED WITHOUT
TELLING YOU WITHOUT YOUR
KNOWLEDGE.
BECAUSE BANK OF AMERICA DID
THAT, YOU ARE BEING TREATED LIKE
A MEMBER OF AL QAEDA.
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
IT DOESN’T MATTER HOW MUCH YOU
DESPISE DONALD TRUMP, OR HOW
MUCH YOU BELIEVE THAT HATRED OF
TRUMP JUSTIFIES THE SPENDING
THIS COUNTRY’S ANCIENT CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
GOING THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE
WOULD SCARE THE HELL OUT OF YOU.
ABSOLUTELY.
A TERRORIST SUSPECT YOU WOULD
THINK?
DOES ANYONE EVEN KNOW ABOUT
THIS?
IS THERE A RECORD OF THIS
INTERVIEW WHY I WOULD LOSE MY
JOB BECAUSE OF IT?
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED TO
SOMEONE.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE IT, BUT IT
DID.
WE ASKED BANK OF AMERICA ABOUT
THIS, THEY CONFIRMED IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED BY NOT DENYING IT.
HERE IS THEIR STATEMENT IN FULL
WHICH MANAGES TO MAKE THE WHOLE
THING EACH CREEPIER ASSUMING
THAT’S POSSIBLE.
QUOTE:  WE DON’T COMMENT ON OUR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WELL, APPARENTLY NOT.
ALL BANKS, IT CONTINUES, HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER FEDERAL
LAW TO COOPERATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SNIRKS IN FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW, END
QUOTE.
NOW, THE LAST PART FROM THE
LAWYER’S PERSPECTIVE IS THE
ESSENCE IN FULL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW.
IT’S THE LAW, WE HAD NO CHOICE.
BUT THAT’S NOT TRUE.
BANK OF AMERICA DID HAVE A
CHOICE.
THE BANK COULD HAVE RESISTED
TURNING OVER INFORMATION ON ITS
INNOCENT CUSTOMERS TO FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS.
BUT BANK OF AMERICA DID NOT DO
THAT.
NOR IS IT CLEAR IF WE’RE GOING
TO BE PRECISE ABOUT IT, THAT
WHAT BANK OF AMERICA DID IS EVEN
LEGAL.
IT TURNS OUT IT’S NOT SIMPLE.
IT’S A GRAY AREA.
WE SPOKE TO A NUMBER OF LAWYERS
ABOUT THIS TODAY.
SOME OF THEM TOLD US THAT WHAT
BANK OF AMERICA DID MIGHT, IN
FACT, NOT BE LEGAL AND COULD, IN
FACT, BE CHALLENGED IN COURT.
ONE KNOWLEDGEABLE ATTORNEY
POINTED TO US 12 U.S. C 433
ALLOWS THE BANKS TO TIP OFF THE
FEDS TO ANY INFORMATION THAT MAY
BE RELEVANT TO A POSSIBLE
VIOLATION OF ANY STATUTE OR
REGULATION.
NOW THE DOJ INSTRUCTS FEDERAL
AGENTS TO REMIND BANKS OF THAT
LAW, AND, OF COURSE, THEY DO
WITH MAXIMUM AGGRESSION.
BUT THE QUESTION IS LEGALLY,
WHAT CONSTITUTES INFORMATION
THAT MAY BE RELEVANCE TO A
POSSIBLE CRIME?
BUYING A MUFFIN IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. ON JANUARY 5TH?
DOES THAT MAKE YOU A POTENTIAL
DOMESTIC EXTREMIST?
ACCORDING TO BANK OF AMERICA,
YES, YES, IT DOES.
THIS IS THE MOMENT WHEN FOR THE
SAKE OF OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
GRANDCHILDREN WHO WILL LIVE
HERE, WE NEED TO PAUSE AND
BREATHE DEEPLY SEARCHING FOR
WISDOM, AVOIDING HYSTERIA AND
ASK WHAT ARE THE RULES?
WHAT FOREGOD’S SAKE IS A
POLITICAL EXTREMIST?
A LOT HANGS ON THAT QUESTION.
MAYBE EVERYTHING.
PLEASE TELL US.
BUT THEY WON’T TELL US.
POINTEDLY THEY WON’T TELL US.
TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE NEW NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN
TOLD REPORTER THAT, QUOTE:
DOMESTIC EXTREMISM IS THE URGENT
CRISIS OF OUR TIME.
ROOTING OUT DOMESTIC POLITICAL
EXTREMISM IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN GETTING A
JOB.
RUNNING YOUR BUSINESS, TENDING
TO YOUR FAMILY.
BUT SULLIVAN DID NOT, AGAIN,
TELLINGLY EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS.
>> SO BUILD BACK BETTER ISN’T
JUST ABOUT ECONOMICS.
IT’S ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY AS
WELL.
AND THEN IT’S ABOUT THE SET OF
ISSUES THAT WORKING FAMILIES IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE FACING EVERY
DAY THAT ARE CHALLENGING THEIR
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS, THE
PANDEMIC, CLIMATE CHANGE, THE
THREAT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENT
EXTREMISM.
>> Tucker: DOMESTIC VIOLENT
INTEREST IT IS THE WORST THING.
NO SENSE OF WHAT THAT MEANS.
WE’RE STARTING TO BELIEVE THEY
ARE NOT DEFINING IT FOR A
REASON.
WHAT’S THE OTHER EXPLANATION?
YESTERDAY AN OP-ED IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" ASKED THIS QUESTION:
ARE PRIVATE MESSAGING APPS THE
NEXT MISINFORMATION HOT SPOT?
PRIVATE MESSAGING APPS SIGNAL.
A BUNCH OF OTHERS.
THEY ARE ENCRYPTED NO ONE CAN
READ IT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" DOESN’T
LIKE THIS.
WHY?
BECAUSE IF THEY CAN’T SEE WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING, MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN’T BE ALLOWED TO SAY IT.
AS THE NEWSPAPER PUT IT QUOTE
THE SHIFT TO PRIVATE MESSAGING
HAS RENEWED A DEBATES OVER
WHETHER ENCRYPTION IS A DOUBLE
EDGED SWORD WHILE THE TECHNOLOGY
PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM BEING SPIED
UPON IT MAY ALSO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR CRIMINALS AND MISINFORMATION
SPREADERS TO DO HARM WITHOUT
GETTING CAUGHT.
NOTICE CRIMINALS AND
MISINFORMATION SPREADERS ARE IN
THE SAME SENTENCE.
THEY ARE PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
THING.
WHAT’S A MISINFORMATION
SPREADER?
WELL IT’S SOMEBODY THAT DOESN’T
AGREE WITH THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
OBVIOUSLY A VIOLENT EXTREMIST
AND THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
IF YOU THINK WE ARE JOKING?
WE ARE NOT.
THEY ARE PULLING THIS THREAD
EVERY DAY.
ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
WE NEED TO START SCREENING THE
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS OF PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR THE GOVERNMENT JUST
TO MAKE SURE.
>> SO, IT’S TIME FOR US TO OPEN
OUR EYES AND RECOGNIZE WHAT’S
GOING ON.
THE FACT THAT WE DO NOT LOOK AT
SOCIAL MEDIA OF POTENTIAL
RECRUITS INTO THE MILITARY